you
a scar
let's try oh it turns red when you're
down to seven that's different
all right let's let's throw the check
this is something a beginner would do
I have an idea though here and then drop
back to c7
Marik
all right so
all right so just have the Queens off
first things first
negate this night my queen isn't around
to watch over the sensitive square
anymore so this move firsts and
yeah let's put the night out I was
thinking about this move let's do this
now how do you defend this it's
uncomfortable this is now very
uncomfortable for like defending this
pawn is not fun
something just feels off now right
any-any move here is just really weird
okay I am now going to take some time
out to get a flight square for my King
and Bishop next step we make sure this
knight doesn't jump in here and have too
much fun so I could take him out
straight away if I want
there's no other spot for my epon than
here
almost there and
[Music]
let's just do this something active pin
the night I don't know if I really want
to take them but
I went mine's may be provoking some some
moves like this and maybe I could
operate on these squares see for square
a little bit better
maybe I will take the night I don't know
has them thinking more than if I would
have played into you seven
well it's just Castle he's unprotected
so I have to be a little bit careful
there's moves like this takes in the
night can return
um yeah let's just go here so they still
have to kind of do awkward stuff to
defend here like this and then I don't
know how you used I'm not sure how white
easily alleviates the pressure on see -
what's the convenient way to untangle I
don't I don't really know
meanwhile what do I do to improve
neither one of us has a
a structural defect
I'm thinking I want to go in for a c5
break
let's start with this before I even play
c5 I'm going to look at a6 you know on
the other hand maybe I should have gone
with this rook yeah III should have kept
this rook here for maybe this idea at
some point and also open up this square
for maybe my king
or night or Bishop yeah I don't like my
choice with the
rook on a 2 c1 I think I think if I
could do it over I play this rook here
all right let's get in a six
you
okay
so I think that
black is looking our white is looking at
this idea
weakens this square
you
okay I'm gonna go here I thought about
this but I feel it's just too weakening
you know they they we can see for I
don't know if I want a week in c5 so I'm
doing this to stop night here he can't
be flushed away so easily
so this is more of a
move than anything at anything else no
okay I could go into c-4 but this was my
primary idea stop night a foreign to see
for this is the one square that they
have a very nice grip over in my
position
um I guess we're gonna come all the way
back I don't like this with tempo
yeah this is pretty serious actually
this would make some sense Bishop e2
there under 30 seconds
hmm
but another thing I can maybe jump in
here
I
to move a little bitty to easy let's go
here he wasn't doing anything maybe put
some pressure
on them clockwise
how can I improve not sure let's back up
defendant I direct pressure now
okay let's do this night takes I'm
taking with the c-pawn so now they
either have a backward pond or an
isolated pond let's see their decision
they should probably do this
okay now they might never be able to
play see form so we start by going here
we're definitely don't want to cease
that see that move
and now our Bishop's going to slip in
and key and then not only pinning the
night but preventing this guy from
moving how do they get out of this pin
I don't see how they get out of that pin
without the bishops help
let's improve the night
this may be an eternal pin
I'll take with the bishop how do you get
out of this pin
they can't get out of this pin they're
lost my King has all day to run over
here
they're never getting out of that pin
it's impossible
keep pinned pieces keep the pieces pin
actually the direct way forward is to
just force through g4
and that's it
I want to overtake g4 and that's it
here we go
and that's going to be it
back to terminal and he turn up in
you